good evening it's 7 o clock this is Sky
News it's one of the two men hoping to
be the next prime minister
over the next hour put your questions to
Jeremy hunt in the battle for number 10
very good evening welcome to Sky News
Centre for this special programme an
uninterrupted hour with the foreign
secretary and conservative leadership
candidate Jeremy Hunt welcome indeed
goodie-goodie viewers over the course
indeed sir over the course of the next
hour going to be asking questions
submitted to Sky News by conservative
voters and examining the issues that
they throw up lots of tricky questions
to come about your plans as Prime
Minister but first something relevant to
your current job and dramatic scenes as
you've seen in Hong Kong tonight where
police have been flashing as you can see
with pro-democracy protesters I know
that you have tweeted about that earlier
on today foreign secretary what is your
message to the authorities there well my
starting point is that I have never had
to fight for my freedom in my life and
my dad was in the Navy and he and his
generation were really responsible for
winning the Cold War and they knew what
it was like to be on the front line
against freedom and he taught me we can
never take our freedoms for granted so
when I look at those situations that
we've just seen in those those terrible
scenes in Hong Kong my heart goes out to
people who do have to fight for their
freedoms and who are worried they could
lose very very precious way of life even
if they use violence well I don't
support violence in any circumstances
but I understand their worries about
changes that are happening in Hong Kong
and when I talk to the Chinese
government about this you know they put
out a statement last week saying this is
an internal affair and it's not for
Britain to meddle in it but we signed an
agreement with China in 1985
I was actually Margaret Thatcher and
Deng Xiaoping who signed the joint
declaration which guarantee what's
called the the one country two systems'
promise for 50 years for Hong Kong and
that has been the foundation of Hong
Kong success so I really hope that there
aren't changes in Hong Kong that
undermine that agreement which is a
legally binding agreement between
Britain and China and as I said today we
stand behind what was in that agreement
we stand behind the freedoms that are
enshrined and we stand behind the people
of Hong Kong doesn't necessarily look as
though China is doing the same thing as
the UK would want them to carry lam the
chief executive who represents China
that is what a lot of these protests are
about they want her to be gone what
would you say to President Xi of China
if you could speak to him well I've met
him but what I would say to President Xi
is look at how special Hong Kong is this
city of just seven million people a
fraction the size of China and yet one
of the world's great centres of
enterprise and it's because of that
special mix in its history of British
and Chinese influence and let it be it
says so much for China if it's prepared
to allow Hong Kong to operate under a
different system with those basic
democratic freedoms and you know I think
that should stay ok we've got lots of
questions for you as you can imagine
over the next hour let's stay with
foreign policy which which is where we
started from these are questions from
our audience and this is from James who
is in Marlow and he says Iran is
increasing enrich uranium in its bid to
gain nuclear weapons will the UK now
reconsider its support for the Iran deal
which has given the Islamic Republic
billions to fund terrorism and war
across the Middle East
well James you are absolutely right to
highlight this issue because it is one
of the biggest worries on my mind at the
moment if you look around the world if
you say which is the part of the world
where we could haven't
suspected war a conflict which draws big
powers in and becomes much much more
significant than the might of first seem
it is here and we have this Iran nuclear
deal which Britain and actually at that
time the United States and the President
Obama signed up to because we knew that
Iran was just 18 months away from
getting a nuclear weapon and I think
that was the right thing to do because I
think today if Iran had a nuclear weapon
things would be even more dangerous but
a deal is a deal and we have said that
we will carry on trading with Iran so on
the side of Iran rather than us on this
we have said that we support this
nuclear deal we're on the side of the
u.s. as it was four years ago under
President Obama but President Trump has
taken a different view we want to
preserve that deal because we don't want
Iran to have nuclear weapons but if Iran
breaks that deal then we're out of it as
well okay so what if President Trump
your Prime Minister next month and
president Trump it's that the phone and
says you know what I'm not happy with
what's going on with Iran and we are
going to launch some sort of attack
what would you say well I can't leave
visit any circumstances where we would
be part of that because we have taken a
different view on this nuclear deal and
the sanctions that America have decided
to impose however what President Trump
is saying in this I totally agree with
him the root cause of instability in the
Middle East are the terrorist
organizations that Iran is sponsoring in
different countries you know we have the
the Hizbullah attacks on Israel we also
have the the Houthis who are launching
missiles into Saudi Arabia and and what
the president is saying is that we
aren't going to get peace in the Middle
East unless Iran recognizes the this
kind of destabilizing activity has to
stop are we on the side of Iran or Saudi
well we believe that in terms of
regional stability
the Saudis do want to preserve peace and
we are very worried that what Iran does
is destabilizing that doesn't mean we
agree with Saudi on everything they do
but but in terms of regional peace we do
think that they are trying to keep the
peace in the Middle East into little
bits well we don't agree with that of
course and we've been very very clear
with Saudi sometimes there are people
that you have a strategic partnership
with and you have to have very difficult
conversations in September I think it
was in New York and you just become
foreign secretary you said you had very
distinct red lines surely chopping a
journalist into little bits
Jamarcus Shoji is crosses that red line
it does and I had a well I had a very
difficult meeting with the Crown Prince
of Saudi Arabia and I went there and
I've had a number of discussions with
the Saudi foreign minister about it and
I've made very clear in public and in
private that kind of thing is totally
against our values and I've done
something else actually Kay I've
organised the world's first-ever
ministerial conference on media freedom
which is happening next week in London
to make sure that we as a country are
flying the flag for the kind of freedoms
that you see people in Hong Kong
protesting for that we have always
supported as a country because you know
we have our our allies we have our
partners we also have well they are our
strategic allies yes closest allies in
the region well I think with them yes we
do delicious why we've not taken it too
far over kajouji
no we have we have very good relations
with other countries in the region as
well and look how closest ally in the
world is the United States and why is
that because you know I think the big
battle that we are going to have to
fight in this century is between open
and closed societies okay and whatever
you think of an individual president in
the end this country under me as Prime
Minister this country will always stand
up for our democratic values and that is
why just a bigger are just amazing that
is why I've made the commitment and I'm
the only candidate in this campaign to
have made a commitment that we will
increase our defense spending to beyond
2 percent of GDP because I want the
world to know at the point of brexit
when
we've got these really big new chapter
opening in our country's history that
Britain is one of the few countries in
the world that has stood up for
democratic values and the security that
you need to underpin them okay witness
here and our voice is loud so how do you
feel about our closest ally as you've
described them in the form of President
Trump as it stands cozying up to
somebody like President Putin who
poisons people on British soil and also
jokes together at the g20 in Osaka about
getting rid of journalists well because
we know that well what that means in
Russia don't we let me say as a starting
point that I don't agree with everything
President Trump says or everything
President Trump does but I met him a
number of times and he is the kind of
person who has no problem if you
disagree with him as long as you're
straight direct and I I talk to him
businessman to businessman we don't
agree on the Iran nuclear deal we don't
agree on climate change I certainly
wouldn't agree with his comments on
journalists but I do agree with him when
he says and he said at the time of the
d-day memorial celebrations that the
alliance between the United Kingdom and
the United States is the greatest in
history and if you look at the world
that we've had for the last 75 years
this has been a world where has been
more prosperity more freedom more peace
than humanity has ever had and the
relationship the alliance the friendship
the shared values between the United
Kingdom the United States is at the
heart of that and as Prime Minister I
will stop at nothing to protect that
okay you're on safe territory with
foreign affairs let's be honest it's
your brief let's move on to brexit
because you can go wrong in foreign
affairs as well you know you're
certainly up to speed on that where are
you on brexit this question from a
Justin butcher from Manchester Justin
says you are prepared to leave the EU
without a deal at the end of October 2/3
of conservative members agree but only a
quarter of the country does won't the
promises that you are making in this
race cost you
a general election or Justin is
absolutely right to ask that question
because we're at a very pivotal moment
in the brexit negotiations and we don't
have a majority in parliament and if we
get this wrong we could end up with an
accidental general election that lets in
Jeremy Corbyn and we would end up with
no brexit at all because the one thing
the Labour Party would not allow him to
do is to deliver brexit now I very
strongly believe sorry to go back to
foreign affairs but when I go around the
world I notice that people have a whole
lot more respect for Britain than we
sometimes seem to have for ourselves and
one of the reasons for that is because
we are one of the oldest and most
respected democracies in the world and
this is a country where people like me
do what the people tell us so I think it
is imperative that we deliver on the
referendum result as you've told us to
do not quite as much detail as you told
us earlier but do go on I mean it seems
pretty scary to me well I think that we
have to recognize that no deal will be
very scary to a lot of people including
the person I met last week running a
factory that makes steel wheels in
Kidderminster he said that his business
could be wiped out by a No Deal brexit
including the farmer I met in Shropshire
a few months earlier who exports 95% of
his lamb to the EU and that's why today
I announced that as Prime Minister there
will be a 20 billion pound support
package for business for farmers for the
fishing community to make sure that if
we do end up in a no deal situation we
can weather that storm but it's not my
first choice and I'd say that if you
look at what both Boris and I are saying
on No Deal it's actually pretty similar
we're both saying that we don't want it
but if it's the only way to deliver
brexit we'd do it the difference is who
is the person who's most likely to get a
deal before we get to that point so we
don't have to make that very very
difficult the difference is that you're
selling a nightmare from what you were
saying today Boris's is selling a dream
billions of
pounds in tariffs for business is a
likelihood chaos on the Irish border
confusion at the ports emergency powers
you talked about today what on earth is
that all about and a loss of business
which you talked about with one of my
colleagues yesterday is a price worth
paying
Boris he's not here so we can't ask him
but here seems to be a dream we come out
of the European Union and all will be
well if we come out of the European
Union without a deal with your plan does
that mean well first of all the point
you've just raised que what a shame that
Boris isn't here because this is an
audition for the most important job in
the country and I would love to debate
these issues with Boris head-to-head
you're going to be subjected to more
scrutiny in that job than answer your
question as Prime Minister I will always
be straight with people and no deal will
be disruptive to businesses up and down
the country disruptive to the farming
industry to the fishing community and I
am someone who comes from a business
background and I know what it's like
when a business is under pressure
because of a sudden change in the market
that you can't control and businesses
are the lifeblood of our country and I
am you know I'd be the first Prime
Minister who's been an entrepreneur so
what I say is yes I am pro-business but
I'm also pro-democracy and we are going
to implement this referendum result
we're going to leave the European Union
and so I say to businesses I will be
there for you that's what I was
announcing today with my plan we will
put in place measures that make it
possible for you to withstand these
challenges and that's what I do you
figures don't add up though according to
none other than our presence Chancellor
this is what he tweeted earlier on today
the fiscal firepower we have built up in
case of a No Deal BRICS it will only be
available for extra spending if we leave
with an orderly transition you're not
necessarily suggesting that if not it
will all be needed to plug the hole and
No Deal BRICS it will make in the public
finances you don't have the war chest
well actually I agree
with what Philip Hammond is saying there
that the what he calls the fiscal
firepower there is what you would need
for an Odile brexit and yes we would you
we would not be able to do some of the
other things we talked about defense
spending earlier that's something I
think is very important it Britain's
gonna walk tall in the world those kind
of spending plans would be delayed if we
have an Odile brexit because we would
need to be helping out businesses to
help them smooth that transition so
that's why I want to go for deal sorry
what would the money come from there's
no there's no money in the war chest
this war chest is here if we have an
orderly brexit yes and so we're gonna
have to use that head room in order to
cushion the impact of a No Deal break so
that's why you know money for the social
care system for the education system all
those things that I'd very much like to
spend will have to wait but that's why
the crucial thing is to send to Brussels
a prime minister who has a better chance
of getting a deal someone that they'll
talk to negotiate with and I don't say
it's going to be easy but it's not
impossible either and I have sat through
the night negotiating big deals stayed
around the table till 3:00 in the
morning come in before breakfast
to try and get something resolved so I
know what it takes to negotiate a deal
this will be a difficult one but it is
possible to do because when you talk to
European leaders you know they want to
solve this problem as well and if we
offer them a sensible solution I know
they'll listen your New Deal or No Deal
depends on what happens between 23rd
24th of July and the end of September
you've brought a new deadline to the end
of September if we're not in a position
where it looks as though we're going to
get a deal by the 31st of October you
said this morning we will stop
negotiating with the European Union you
spent three years best part of three
years trying to do a deal as part of
mrs. Mayer's government what makes you
think you can do it in six weeks eight
weeks well it's it's challenging but it
will be a different approach to the
approach to reason they took now I don't
want to
sit here with UK and every single
disagreement I had with Teresa may
because I think she has a tremendous
sense of duty as our Prime Minister I
think she put herself heart and soul
into this the reality is though that
that approach didn't work and what I
would do that's different to that is
first of all I'd be going for a
different deal a her deal well her deal
have this thing called the backstop for
Northern Ireland which would have meant
that we had to follow the --use customs
tariffs effectively until the EU gave us
permission not to do that that was never
something I believed in I argued against
it and I didn't think it would get
through Parliament but the negotiating
reason why I think that approach came
unstuck was that in the end the EU
didn't want to offer us any more
concessions because they didn't believe
that she was going to be able to get it
through Parliament and my approach will
be quite different I will have in my
negotiating team the DUP who are the
Irish party that we have an alliance
with Northern Irish party we have an
alliance with in Parliament mostly the
yes most of the time the ERG who are the
the brexit purists inside the
Conservative Party and also Scottish and
Welsh conservatives so that when we make
those do you think might make a
difference to our European colleagues
well what what our European friends want
to know is that when we make an offer we
can actually get it through Parliament
so if you've got people from all these
groups inputting they know we'll be
serious and so what I said today is this
is not going to be something that takes
a huge amount of time we will put
together that package in August we will
then over six weeks yeah
it's but I think that is that from
scratch no because I think a lot of what
we have in the current agreement people
can live with the main issue of
contention is the backstop so we will
six weeks reading ago stating the
backstop no six weeks coming together
with an alternative plan and by the way
conservative MPs like Greg hands and
Nicky Morgan I've been doing some
brilliant work even this week in coming
up with an alternative approach using
technology so we'll do that then in
September we'll take it to the EU and
I'm not saying that we will
clewd a deal in September but I think
three weeks is plenty long enough for me
as Prime Minister to make a judgment as
to whether there is a prospect of a deal
that can get through Parliament what
would have to be the situation on the
30th of September for you to think you
know what it I potentially could extend
past the 31st of October well I'm not
looking to make any kind of extension as
far as I'm concerned a day beyond the
29th of March when we were supposed to
have left is a day too long with respect
wasn't my question no but my answer to
you would be that I don't think we'll
just be me that knows I think the whole
country will know if there is a prospect
having put a deal to the European Union
that we know can get through Parliament
if they're interested I mean they
they'll probably get back to us in a
matter of days and then if there is that
prospect of a deal then of course I'm
going to think about the farmers and the
fishing community and the small
businesspeople and the people on high
street shops and I would try and get
that deal through Halloween it's not a
do or die for you then well I think the
only difference between me and Boris is
that I've said that if we have a deal
and it just needs a few extra days in
order to get through Parliament then I'm
going to be thinking of those business
people up and down the country
well Boris has said that even if we have
a deal
and it hasn't got through Parliament
then that's it although the game over
would it be the end of our present
tenure in 2020 when would it be
well I'm said I would be prepared to
accept a few extra days to allow
parliamentary passage of a deal that we
have agreed will work but I'm not
talking about anything significantly
long of course not because I think we're
going to know pretty quickly if the EU
are prepared to talk about this or not
but this is all pie in the sky really
isn't it because our European colleagues
or friends as you've described us there
this is what they have been saying as
you well know but just to remind our
viewers Michel Barnier saying this
treaty is the only one possible in other
words we are not going to renegotiate
and there is no jean-claude Juncker
there will be no renegotiation of the
withdrawal agreement and if that wasn't
enough for your friends and
colleague Angela Merkel the exit
agreement will not be changed well this
is a group of people who spent two years
coming to an agreement with Theresa May
and this is a negotiation so of course
they're going to take a position like
that at the outset but when you talk to
those people I've talked to some of them
they also say that if a new Prime
Minister comes forward with new
proposals that are sensible of course
they will look at the package and I
think that's what would happen and I
don't actually said that to you you meet
them all the time too well I just want
well I've had a conversation with Angela
Merkel okay Oh exactly what I've just
said to you of course we will look at
any proposals made by a new UK prime
minister because she wants to solve this
problem and you know providing was
sensible I think the approach that I've
laid out is a sensible approach and a
fair approach and I think that it's in
Germany's interests as well not just
because of the the risks to German
industry but but someone like Angela
Merkel is very conscious of the global
importance of a strong partnership
between the UK and Germany and so of
course they are looking at this saying
where's the win-win where's the solution
that can work so Angela Merkel has taken
you to one side and said I know what I'm
saying in public Jeremy but actually
with the new prime minister we could
there is some wriggle room we could
renegotiate a little bit with the
withdrawal agreement what she said is
she will look at the package and I think
she would look at it with an open mind
I'm not going to say to you here that
this is going to be easy and that's why
what is important is that we choose a
negotiator someone who genuinely has a
prospect of changing Minds someone who
has experience of these kinds of
negotiations and someone you know
they're willing to talk to because the
first rule of a negotiation is you don't
do a deal with someone you don't trust
and so we need to send someone that we
can have those negotiations it's
suggesting they wouldn't trust Boris
Johnson I'm not going to say anything
about anyone else I'm just saying that
look at me I believe that my credentials
are someone who could possibly pull this
thing off but I would never pretend to
anyone that is country
when she says that is representing she's
a senior States person of course
representing Germany or representing
other members of the European Union I
think she is representing what a lot of
people think in the EU which is that
this is a very difficult problem they
too would like to resolve it they don't
I think want to trap Britain in the EU
against its will and people like me make
it absolutely clear that we are leaving
but part of the thing that will persuade
them is what I did today which is to
announce very credible plans as to how
we would manage an Odile brexit so that
they know that we're not afraid of
leaving without a deal it's not our
choice just like it wouldn't be their
choice but that we are ready and that's
why I think it's very important that the
very first thing that our Prime Minister
needs to do on going through the door of
number 10 is to press go on all the No
Deal preparations how would you get a No
Deal if you've if this didn't come off
how would you get a No Deal through the
British Parliament given that they've
already voted against it
well I think this is why in the end this
debate about the 31st of October is a
bit of a fake debate because whoever's
Prime is whether it's me or whether it's
Boris is going to have to deal with the
fact that Parliament may well try to
stop a no deal breaks it you may well in
return prorogue Parliament would you do
the same I wouldn't I think it's
absolutely not 100 percent guarantee 100
percent not you know we voted to leave
the EU because we wanted to restore
parliamentary democracy you cannot in
that situation force through a No Deal
brexit by closing down Parliament either
the British people would not accept that
including I think many people who voted
for brexit the way you avoid all those
difficult choices that could face me and
they could face boris is to have a prime
minister who has a realistic prospect of
negotiating a deal that can get through
Parliament and that's what I'm offering
okay um
Richard Piper is 65 years old and he is
from Tunbridge and this is what he has
to say still about brexit you may need
more water
how are you going to persuade countries
with big economies to give us a better
trade deal than we currently enjoy with
the EU when our negotiating strength
will be diminished well I think the
answer that question Richard is that you
know someone who set up their own
business
I want to turbocharge our economy I
think our big opportunity now we've got
the top universities in Europe three of
the top ten universities in the world we
have more technology entrepreneurs more
medicines being developed here and we
could be the world's next Silicon Valley
and that is my ambition for our country
to set us up for what's called the
fourth Industrial Revolution now if all
the technology all the really exciting
new things that are happening when it
comes to those technological
developments are happening here in
Britain then the other side are going to
want to do a trade deal with us every
bit as much as we want to do a trade
deal with them so it's about creating
that balance of advantage that makes the
UK a country that you have to do
business with if the other side is the
European Union and we haven't paid our
divorce bill because we have come out
without a deal interesting oh you know I
just that would be the first time by the
way since the Napoleonic Wars that we've
defaulted on a debt mm-hmm do you want
to be that Prime Minister no I think we
are a country that pays our legal debts
as a business so we will pay the divorce
as a businessman I pay my bills and I
think the kind of country we are is a
country that pays our bills but some of
that 39 not coming there is about coming
because you know I'm absolutely cleared
of the 39 billion what is legally owing
we will pay but some of that money is
for the transition period well you know
there's a discussion to be had some of
you did the deal didn't you your
government did the deal so you know what
the figures are well I think that a big
chunk of that money depending on who you
talk to up to nine yes I know you don't
agree I'm just telling you that there
was some debate about this but you know
several billion pounds of comfortable
with as Prime Minister well I'm telling
you what I would not be
comfortable with and that is not paying
the money that we illegally oh and let
me tell you why that is because if we
know that I want to illegally oh and you
obviously do know so you want to I'm
saying that there are several billions
of that is to do with the transition
period that we wouldn't need but my
point is this if we're going to make a
success of brexit we need to have a
friendly relationship with our next-door
neighbors unlike a divorce where you you
might move to the other side of town or
even something completely different when
you use separate as a couple we are
going to remain next-door and it is in
all of our interests that we have a
friendly relationship and you would
poison that relationship for decades to
come if we don't pay the money that is
legally do however it will take longer
to get that money and it won't be as
much as thirty nine billion if we don't
do a deal so I think that's a big
incentive for the EU to make sure that
we do a deal however we took part in a
withdrawal agreement you were very well
aware of the details of that withdrawal
agreement I'm sure that you talked about
it in cabinet an awful lot of the time
the European Union is expecting 39
billion pounds as part of that divorce
agreement are we going to adopt that
sort of British holiday make a tactic of
speaking slower and louder and hoping
that they understand what we're trying
to say well that is not what happened
with me as Prime Minister because if
you're negotiating a deal you have to
have trust between both sides they have
to think that you're being reasonable
they have to want to do a deal with you
and if you start saying we're not gonna
pay you the money that that's legally
yours
they just won't talk to you and so
that's why I would not go down that
route and I think if you go down that
route you are closing off the best
solution for the United Kingdom which is
actually to negotiate a deal that works
for both sides not easy to do but as I
say not impossible and I think the best
thing for businesses up and down the
country the best thing for our union by
the way you know Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland to get that a question
about the Union coming up so we'll come
back to that if I might just pause you
there but you're not going to give me a
on how much no I think you know we have
to look into that thirty nine billion
pounds very careful of it I'm not gonna
give you a figure quarter sorry K you're
very persuasive but just not on
obviously not on this on we're talking
about trust you've talked about earlier
on today about six billion pounds that
you would be making available to
mitigate the problems with tariffs that
fishermen and farmers would have here in
the United Kingdom so it would be a sort
of transitional amount of cash that was
made available to them if there was no
deal until we could do a deal with the
European Union or whoever else it might
be we spoke to the WTO earlier on today
and they said that basically you can't
subsidize exports and they are like
cutting down on all subsidies including
farming and Fisheries yes those are the
WTO rules and let me be clear the money
I'm announcing today is not a subsidy
for tariffs because that would be
against WTO rules this is an amount of
money to help those businesses
transition from one business model to
another if you export
95% of your lamb to Europe and suddenly
you've got a 40% tariff on that then the
European market is going to be very
difficult for you so gonna have to
change your business
maybe you'll export more lamb
domestically maybe you'll change the
products that you sell in order to deal
with those change circumstances so what
I want to do is to give them support
over a period of years to change their
businesses so they can adapt to a very
different situation fishermen and
farmers all know I think we need we will
need to help other industries as well
well you know look at the or 2,000
people are directly or indirectly
employed in the car industry 10% tariffs
on vehicles a lot of jobs are gonna go
that is why you know you can never be
complacent about the effect of No Deal I
mean I but we don't know the currency is
a very good example actually I remember
in the 1970s actually I can remember the
1980s all the problems we have with
British Leyland now you look at our car
industry employing nearly a million
people and globally incredibly
competitive
and you know for them it will be a very
serious issue to deal with no deal and
so yes they would need support to
transition as well but that is why you
know choose a prime minister who has a
chance of getting us a deal
okay the car industry tariffs help with
terrace fire I'm not offering help with
tariffs for anyone I'm offering help to
transition deal that you're offering to
farmers and fishermen to the car
industry I would offer support yes okay
because they need to transition their
business models we need to move on I
know we've got an hour but it's already
racing by at Jack McCabe from London
when you become the UK prime minister
how are you ensure that the UK remains a
country of four nations in other words
how do you fix the vexation of the
backstop well I'm glad I can't answer
that question let me tell you where I'm
coming from
I've got Welsh blood Irish blood I spent
two happy years of my childhood in
Scotland and I am a unionist to my core
and as Prime Minister I will never allow
the breakup of the United Kingdom and
that's why I think it's very important
as we negotiate this brexit deal that we
do something that works for all four
parts of UK because that is what is
brilliant you know brexit more important
well the union has to be the starting
point but brexit matters too because one
of the great things about our union is
that we symbolize democracy across the
world and therefore we have to implement
breaks if we have to do it in a way that
works for the Union now the backstop is
obviously the reason why the main reason
why brexit has not gone through the
House of Commons and that's why we need
to find a different solution what's your
solution my solution is based on
technology
it's what the Germans describe as
invisible borders I think that most
borders across the world in the next
decade will go in that direction and I
think there is technology there now that
means that it's a well I believe there
is well no the Home Office actually well
the home secretary believes there is and
I believe there is as well because you
can do checks away from borders but
let's be clear the the people who don't
accept this
so I was just gonna say a possible
solution we had a leaked document from
the Home Office saying possible solution
incredibly complicated very expensive
and it wouldn't be deliverable until
2030 so if you then say well we'll take
that away from the border does that mean
that we have a border in the Irish Sea
and if we do what does that mean for
your colleagues from the DUP that you're
going to take to negotiate because
they're not gonna want that other well
you've taken one leaked document if I
may say that you know my impression
having read many government documents on
this is that it is that it is this is
wrong
I think overall it is technically
possible and it's a question of creating
a negotiating environment where it is
also politically acceptable to the EU
and to the government in the Republic of
Ireland and you know that is what I
think if we send the right Prime
Minister we have a chance before 2030
well this is one selective quality
possible-- now no and you don't feel
that we need to have a border on the
Irish ports and thus is by default a
border within the Irish Sea well I think
you can do these things by having checks
that are done a source at the factory
one end or the other you can do it by
you use of technology so people register
in advance on the internet you have
trusted trader schemes there are all
sorts of ways of doing it I don't think
it's a question of what's technically
possible it's a question of politically
negotiating to make that part of the
deal okay well and eat in them wants to
talk to you about trust if we may he's
in a skirt he's 51 years old and this is
what auntie has to say do you recognise
the role you and your colleagues have
played in the loss of public faith in
politicians and what do you personally
intend to do to restore public trust
well there is only one way right now to
restore trust and that is to deliver
what we as parliamentarians promised at
the last election that we were going to
leave the European Union and
particularly for the people who voted
for brexit that is the
single issue of trust that we're failing
on now I'm someone who voted three times
for a deal that would have meant that
we've left the European Union by now but
I think all MPs on both sides of the
debate need to understand that issue of
trust and what I would say to Andy is
that is one thing we need to do but then
the other thing we need to do is to
bring the country together after well
I'll tell you how we do that Kay we have
to do what we promised for the 52% and
they want us to leave the European Union
leave the single market leave the
customs union because that's what voted
for at the last March we did and that is
why no I'm just being honest with people
that Parliament a hung parliament it's
not a parliament that the conservative
party controls could seek to block that
31st of October exit but let me tell you
how we unite the country because there's
the that's the other thing you also then
have to have a brexit that works for the
48% and the people who voted for remain
who are who are worried and I talked to
a lot of people who voted for brexit but
also to people who voted remain and what
they are worried about is that brace it
could change the fundamental character
of our country as an open outward
looking internationally minded country
and that is not going to happen not with
a conservative brexit the brexit ears I
know they don't want that kind of break
so they want us to continue to be open
to the world that's one of the great
things about our country and so we have
to show and I think if we can deliver
that type of brexit in 10 years time
remain as or people who voted remain
will see that actually brexit has worked
it's been a great success and it hasn't
changed the fundamental tolerance of our
country and I think that is how we bring
the country together big if there isn't
it
well do the Ring brexit is of course
going to be bumpy but I just say this we
could have some confidence I mean we
have faced much much bigger challenges
than this this in our history before and
you know I look up look at this as a bit
like I I thought when I was starting a
business this is one of those moments
we're a new chapter is opening sky's the
limit we can make this one very
appropriate
Boris famously may promises on the side
of a bus
what would you pledge writ large on the
side of a bus or let me say this a Boris
promised on the side of a bus an extra
350 million every week for the NHS I
actually delivered that promise you did
and Boris promised brexit I will deliver
brexit okay what would you have us yeah
should we talk non brexit for a moment
yes because okay well four things first
of all I want you but I'm gonna say them
very very very unless we have four buses
yeah okay number one Britain that walks
tall in the world and that's why I've
said I'll spend more money on defense
why I will cherish our special
relationship with the United States but
more importantly when you see those
scenes in Hong Kong a country that
stands out for democratic values that's
number one on the second bus I think we
conservatives have to have a social
mission as well as an economic mission
I was health secretary for nearly six
years but actually I want our social
mission to be in education I'm teaching
my five-year-old daughter to read at the
moment and reading about Biff and buff
and kipper is is quite nice relaxation
at the end of the day but you realize
that getting a child to read is a big
deal and nearly a quarter of primary
school leavers don't learn to read or
write properly and this is a terrible
thing to leave people when they go out
into the world so many when your two
buses can I do the third and the fourth
very super quickly yes you can although
Boris it's only made two okay third one
turbocharged the economy we've talked
about Silicon Valley and the fourth one
is actually a promise for the
Conservative Party and that is that by
the time we fight the next election I'm
going to get more young people to vote
conservative because we can't be the
party of aspiration and s the most
aspirational people in the country are
supporting us that brings us beautifully
to our next
question and this is Grace Esprit and
she is 19 years old and she's from Wigan
in Lancashire she says as party leader
what would you do to try to engage young
people in politics and to support the
Conservative Party well great question
and this is what I would say to grace we
have no future as a Conservative Party
unless we get people like you voting for
us and that means understanding your
aspirations now when I was 19 years old
when I was Grace's age that was actually
the year that I joined the Conservative
Party and my dreams then were to set up
my own business buy a house and save up
for a family that would actually
Conservative Party policy back in the
1980s and so we have to recognise that
for young people now buying a house in
much much harder than it was when you or
I were with that age and so we've got to
do something about that we have to
recognise some unfairness a--'s for
young people however much I talk to mums
and dads on the doorstep
I cannot justify 6% interest rates on
student loans I think it's unfair I
support our tuition for your reforms but
that needs to change
so we have to tap into their aspirations
but the other thing we have to do is to
show them that we share their values on
things like climate change you know they
look at us and they say we're going to
be around in in 50 years time you oldies
may not be are you really going to look
after the planet and we are the
Conservative Party we believe in
conservation we want to protect the
Greenbelt I mean what are your plans as
far as trying to save the planet are
concerned we know what the government's
plans are 2050 carbon neutral etcetera
etcetera
what do you do at home well I think like
every family bless me Dan you would I I
probably do eat a little bit less shred
me but more for health reasons but you
know we've moved to metal straws rather
than plastic straws it's just a small
example obviously we're much more
conscientious about recycling the
secretary you travel all over the globe
though what's your carbon footprint
there well
you know I think it is important to
travel and represent our country and you
know that is everyone things that goes
with the territory but I think that as a
country you know we will be the first in
the world to sign up to a legally
binding NetZero 2050 target that's a big
transition we're already on that journey
but what nineteen-year-old say to us is
look we know we've done something but
have we done enough an answer is not yet
okay how do you convince people like
grace though or are younger me because
you know you are if I might say a
quintessential Home Counties posh why
aren't you I mean your your father was
an admiral when you were 19 you just
finished being head boy at Charterhouse
I'm from the same place as Grace I when
I was 19 lived in a council house in
Wigan and I worked on the meat counter
at aster to try and earn some extra
money how do you talk to a younger me or
to grace to convince me that I want to
vote conservative well first of all let
me say this you know I went to a Potter
school I had a fantastic education and I
was very lucky and I also felt deeply
uncomfortable that because I was lucky
enough to go to that school
I might have better life chances than
someone with equal talents equal
ambition equal energy who didn't have
the chance to go to to get such a great
education I am incredibly proud of the
education reforms that have been
championed by Michael Gove under this
Conservative government that have
improved the quality of state schools so
that a number of them are as good as
chart house the school I went to and I
think that's a fantastic reform but I
still think we have a national blind
spot and that's why I said I want
education to be our social mission and I
want to tell you what it is okay we've
thought a lot about the half of school
leavers who go to university on the
whole get a pretty good education but
what about the school leavers who don't
if this was Germany or Switzerland
nearly all of them would leave with a
rigorous qualification that meant that
they could earn the average salary
and I think we should be the
Conservative government that promises
that every single young person will
leave education with a rigorous
qualification because we are the party
that wants to put a ladder in front of
everyone as they start out on their life
whether they choose to climb that ladder
or not that's up to them but we should
be the party that makes sure that
everyone has that ladder
okay so Boris I think it's fair to say
connects with younger voters he's always
up for a laugh tell us a joke I was
dreading new asking something like that
well I think in this campaign the the
best jokes I've seen a probably Peter on
the Internet the first time in my life
actually
the Internet's been quite kind of me I
think it's because they think I'm the
underdog and they actually ran a
campaign to tell Gerry what his slogan
should be for this leadership campaign
so we had hashtag take a punt on hunt
hashtag jezza's the bezu and then the
one that you're really not going to try
and say is hashtag hunt emic hunt face
it always makes me laugh is BBC
hospitality but that's another story
let's move on to Oliver Dooley from
Birmingham he says given your record in
the Department of Health how would you
act differently when managing the
country well let me tell Oliver the
thing that really changed me when I was
health secretary and that was the first
real crisis I had to leave deal with was
mid staffs and the department or some
people in the department cautioned me
not to meet the mid staffs families I
ignore that advice and I met a lady who
at the NHS does a fantastic job most of
the time but sometimes we get it wrong
and I met a lady who'd lost her mother
in a really horrible death amidst us and
she looked me in the eye and she said
Jeremy you could change this and I
decided that I wanted to make the NHS
the safest highest quality health care
in the world and by the time I finished
I had my battles but nearly three
million more patients were using good or
outstanding hospitals including actually
the hospital that used to be called mid
staffs which also really raised its
standards of care which is massive
credit to the staff who were there but
to answer all of his question I had a
very bitter battle with the junior
doctors I I wanted to improve standards
of care a weekend because we had some
data that suggested that the the
mortality rates were higher for people
admitted weekends and could I have
handled those things better well of
course you learn and I don't think I
communicated my message as well as I
could have to junior doctors they were
very active on Facebook I wasn't very
active on social media so what do I take
away from that I think as a politician
you can never spend too much time
communicating with the public and I
think as a Prime Minister you have to be
very open to doing it via par the reason
I'm doing interviews like this I think
you have to make yourself accessible but
also on social media also you know
continuously not just on on occasions
like elections and that's really the
lesson I learned sorry but it did take
six years to try and do those deals in
in the NHS you're trying to set a
deadline of six weeks to sort out brexit
yes but it's not like we're we're
starting from a standing start you know
we we've been debating these issues
thinking about these issues
really for the last three years so we
have made a lot of progress and I think
the elements of the deal that need to be
changed in order to get it through
Parliament and laws get us out of the EU
are are relatively small important but
small which is why I think it can be
done I'm interesting you were talking
about some of what you managed to
achieve I mean you were criticized for
being a micromanager creating a climate
of fear incessant pressure to reach
targets impossible to hit because of the
financial squeeze how much does that
criticism hurt you don't go into public
life if you're not expecting criticism
and I think the real thing that would
have hurt is five years on from being
health secretary if
people weren't able to look at things in
the NHS and point to things that got
better and in every single disease
category whether it's cancer strokes
heart attacks outcomes got better in my
time as health secretary but the area
they didn't which is I think what what
you're mentioning was the waiting times
both for elective care people needing
new hips and knees and that kind of
thing
and also for Ernie and why was that
because we had this pressure of an aging
population and that was why towards the
end of my time I negotiated the
biggest-ever funding increase for the
NHS and what that's going to allow us to
do is to Train many many more doctors
and nurses because in the end the way
that we will reduce those waiting times
is to increase the capacity of a system
and you know they would start to look
for more cash well I actually managed to
get quite a lot of extra cash during my
time as Health's patients waiting for
surgery or other elective treatments
rose from 2.5 million to 4 million yes
but you know after I've been health
secretary for a couple of years I
managed to negotiate an extra eight
billion pounds for the NHS but but this
is the figure that perhaps really
illustrates the challenge facing the NHS
over the last five years there are a
hundred thousand more staff in the NHS
and there are also a hundred thousand
more vacancies so we have been
recruiting more people but we need even
more because of the pressures of an
aging population and that's why I think
probably the single decision that I'm
most proud of as health secretary was
one that I took in 2016 with the support
of treasom a which is one of the biggest
ever increases in the number of doctors
and nurses we train increasing the
number of doctors we train by a quarter
number of nurses were trained by a
quarter now it takes three years to
train a nurse seven years to train a
doctor so you won't see those
differences for a few years but when we
do I think that's going to make a
massive difference yes social care was
part of your brief as well didn't do
very well there did you it was part of
my brief formerly for my last six months
in the job and
this I think should be our our second
big social mission I talked about
abolishing illiteracy Mike I was very
close to my grandmother she died a few
months before her hundred and first
birthday and I will never forget
watching those last few months of her
life when she she slowly lost one
faculty after another and I think we are
a country where we want every single
older person to be treated with dignity
and respect and at the moment in our
social care system if we're honest that
doesn't always happen so I want us to be
a good I've done that when you run the
well what I did was I negotiated a
ten-year plan for the NHS and I always
said the next thing I wanted to do is to
negotiate a ten-year plan for the social
care system and actually bring those two
systems together but then I moved to
being foreign secretary so this is what
I'd like to do in number ten the dignity
and respect for the women of Northern
Ireland who can't have an abortion even
if there they have been raped or have
been a victim of incest
well I authorized as health secretary
for those women to get those abortions
paid for and delivered by the NHS in
England because those issues are
devolved to Scotland Wales Northern
Ireland they're not decided in
Westminster and I think we need to find
a way around those issues so that's what
I did Stella Creasy wanted to change the
rules so that women in Northern Ireland
could have abortions at home so they
wouldn't have to get on an aeroplane and
have an abortion in an area that they
didn't know surrounded by people that
they didn't know you voted against that
because we have a constitutional
settlement that says that those very
difficult issues should be decided in
Northern Ireland in Scotland and Wales
in England and I think that this would
be the wrong moment to unpick that
constitutional settlement but what I
don't want to do it's not no it's not
it's not about that at all I wanted to
find a solution and so I said yes the
NHS in England will
pay so that those women can get those
abortions but you would like women in
England to not be able to have abortions
at 12 weeks wouldn't you well how I
voted is a matter of public record but
I've made it clear that as Prime
Minister I won't change the law there's
no prospect of Parliament changing its
view on that and so that's not going to
change why'd you hold that for you well
why do any of us hold views on these
very difficult issues it's it's finished
yes I do very much so but it's instinct
victory the guy believed passionately in
equality and I believe passionately in
women's rights and we all wrestle with
how to interpret our views on these
things but um you know I've said that
with respect to abortion the law is not
going to change while I'm Prime Minister
because it is a in this country and I
think rightly it has always been a free
vote issue for Parliament
we're out of time thank you so much for
joining us really appreciate very
quickly did we should say that although
he didn't agree to debate you directly
on Sky News the offer is still open to
Boris Johnson to come in and answer our
audiences questions I promise to be good
stay with us for full analysis from our
political editor Beth Rigby
thank you very much indeed for joining
us and for watching as the battle for
number 10 is hosted here at Sky News
with the Foreign Secretary potentially
the next prime minister we'll know by
the end of July Jeremy Hunt thank you
thank you
[Music]